At last, mom and dad are back together.
That's right, Marvel friends and fiends: Sony
Pictures, Marvel Studios, and the Walt Disney
Company have finally set aside their differences,
returned to the negotiation table, and agreed
to make a third Spider-Man movie together.
"Let's try that again."
Sony and Marvel confirmed on Friday, September
27th that an agreement had been reached to
allow Marvel Studios president Kevin Feige
to produce another Spidey flick to follow
2017's Spider-Man: Homecoming and 2019's Spider-Man:
Far From Home.
This means that the ever-charming Tom Holland,
the third actor to step into the Spider-Man
suit and the man largely considered the best
Peter Parker yet, will indeed swing back into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and reprise
his role as the friendly neighborhood hero.
"That's what it said on the news, and the
news never lies."
The peace-restoring meeting happened just
recently, with Marvel, Sony, and Disney executives
inking the new deal on the evening of Thursday,
September 26th.
An important aspect of this agreement is,
of course, the money, which is something that
contributed to Sony and Marvel splitting in
the first place.
On August 20th, 2019, it was announced that
the two studios were unable to see eye-to-eye
on how to rework their 2015 deal that gave
Feige producing power in the Spider-Man franchise,
let Holland's Spider-Man appear in Marvel
movies, and granted Disney, which owns Marvel
Studios, five percent of day-one box office
profits as well as all merchandising revenue.
Disney reportedly requested a 50 percent co-financing
stake in the franchise, which Sony is said
to have denied outright.
Though subsequent reports claimed that the
House of Mouse actually asked for a 30 percent
share, it was evident that money was making
both studios more than a little tense.
"Now get outta here."
Thankfully, Sony, Disney, and Marvel brass
have now agreed that the latter two companies
will receive 25 percent of the profits on
the third Spider-Man movie, with Sony retaining
75 percent.
Additionally, Disney will continue earning
merchandising profits.
This newly confirmed third Spider-Man movie
doesn't yet have a title, but it does have
a release date: July 16, 2021.
It also has Homecoming and Far From Home producer
Amy Pascal on board to continue her producing
role.
Feige expressed gratitude and excitement about
the new deal being struck, saying in a statement
released alongside the news,
"I am thrilled that Spidey's journey in the
MCU will continue, and I and all of us at
Marvel Studios are very excited that we get
to keep working on it.
Spider-Man is a powerful icon and hero whose
story crosses all ages and audiences around
the globe."
Unsurprisingly, Pascal felt the same way,
saying,
"This is terrific.
Peter Parker's story took a dramatic turn
in Far From Home and I could not be happier
we will all be working together as we see
where his journey goes."
Perhaps the best part of this news is that
the upcoming movie isn't the only project
Holland is going to be a part of at the House
of Heroes.
According to Variety, the new agreement between
Sony and Marvel details that Holland's Spider-Man
will appear in at least one future Marvel
Studios film.
"Oh.
This is nice."
Holland also has a bright future ahead at
Sony.
When the Sony-Marvel divorce was first confirmed,
it was reported that Holland was contracted
for two future films under Sony Pictures.
Now, it stands to reason that one of those
projects is the third Spider-Man movie everyone's
freaking out about right now, but what about
the other one?
It doesn't seem as though it's the forthcoming
Marvel movie Holland's now slated for, since
that project is housed at a completely different
studio.
So, what could that be?
Thanks to a tease from Feige himself, it's
likely that yet another movie Holland's Spider-Man
will be in is one under the umbrella of Sony's
Spider-Verse, which includes Spider-Man: Into
the Spider-Verse, Venom, and the impending
films Venom 2, Morbius, and Kraven the Hunter.
As Feige dished,
"[Spider-Man] also happens to be the only
hero with the superpower to cross cinematic
universes, so as Sony continues to develop
their own Spidey-verse you never know what
surprises the future might hold."
All in all, September 27th, 2019 will go down
in history as a victorious day for the folks
at Sony, Disney, and Marvel, as well as for
fans of Spider-Man, the MCU, and Tom Holland
himself.
Now that the web-slinger has officially returned
to the MCU, the only thing left to do is figure
out a name for the new Spider-Man movie.
How about "Spider-Man: Home Sweet Home"?
"That is literally the coolest sentence anyone
has ever said."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
MCU characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.